okay I've got a piece of crystalline
bismuth so you can actually take sort of
pellets of bismuth metal and actually
heat it up
I've seen people I've seen photos of
people doing this on their home sort of
cookers they have their ovens and things
but you can make them in the lab so you
get crystals of bismuth out which look
like this which is actually really
really pretty and there are websites
where people have made lots of these
crystals and they're selling them for
collectors and things which is quite
nice bismuth is interesting because it
is the heaviest element that is not
regular active you can imagine the
nucleus the centre of the atom rather
like a blob of water and if you imagine
a drop of water as it gets bigger and
bigger it becomes unstable and will
easily split into two and it just
happens that bismuth is the larger size
that's not regular active the
interesting thing about bismuth actually
is that it's long been regarded as been
bismuth-209
long being regarded as being the the
heaviest non radioactive element and
technically actually that's not true
it was actually found I think about five
years ago now it was actually proven to
be an alpha emitter so it's actually a
radioactive element emits alpha
particles so here is a very old sample
of bismuth this is a bismuth rod and you
can see it's packed up really quite
nicely but we can open this and we can
go in and have a look to see what it is
you know so here if we pull it out
carefully but actually it's it's kind of
a little bit pedantic I suppose because
the half-life of the this bismuth-209
as they found it specially about at 1.9
times 10 to the power 19 years it's
half-life that's the time it takes for
say a kilo of bismuth for 500 grams of
it to decompose to its its daughter
element which i think is valium 205 i'm
right and so that half-life is actually
longer than the current age of the
universe so for all intents and purposes
is still quite stable I think they
actually call it metastable it is used
particularly in an alloy which called
woods metal which is a very low melting
alloy
we'll even melt in boiling water and
there are endless
practical jokes where you could buy
woods metal spoons and you give it
somebody to stir their tea and it melted
in their tea and they look surprised
see bismuth yeah really old sample from
Johnson Matthey now let's see if we can
find out what the purity is so it's a
99.9 percent really quite nice sample of
bismuth rod bismuth surprisingly is not
very poisonous compared to the fact that
lead is very poisonous and so there are
some suggestions that we should be
exploring more the chemistry of bismuth
as a catalyst because if it works well
then it could be used in chemical
processes with much less danger than
some of these other materials so if we
can push it out from this old paper
packaging and you can see it's packaged
really quite nicely here you can see the
bismuth metal itself bismuth is used
this in catalysis to attenuate selective
reactions so perhaps we might use
bismuth with a platinum group metals
like palladium or platinum even to make
chemistry go a little bit more
selectively it's really beautiful
element they're really nice so we'll pop
that back in there nice and safe why
have you got that where'd that come from
I bought it because it's so pretty and I
bought it from a shop I can't remember
actually which shop now but I collect
these sorts of things very big pretty
looking sort of metallic things and
crystals and as you can see it's really
nice and iridescent so it's got a tiny
topside layer and it shines like sort of
you know it's all all colors of the
rainbow which is really really pretty in
my opinion okay